monsieur antonio papa merci beaucoup
d'être ici je suis très contente de vous
avoir en entrevue parce que c'est plutôt
rare que vous accorder des entrevues
mais je suppose que votre réputation se
sent attaquée et vous avez l'intention
de la défendre qu'est ce que c'est
l'objectif de nous donner une entrevue
voix pour dit la vérité vraiment oui
mais parce que vous trouvez qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses fausses qui circulent
à votre sujet chaque jour d'un
histogramme facebook il ya pas un jeu il
n'y a pas quelque chose de beau jeu mais
c'est vrai et tout ça il faut
complètement faux bond par exemple on
attaque votre réputation pour quelle
raison je suis le wall street jeudi par
le wall street
je démarre à montréal des accusations
que je fais des affaires avec la mafia
c'est des choses comme ça que pour moi
faire beaucoup de dommages
personnellement c'est ça ce qui est
intéressant mais c'est papa c'est que
votre nom est sorti dans les enquêtes
on a vu ce nom là avec des gens qu'on
connaît qu'on ait construit depuis très
longtemps donc que ce soit vito rizutto
et moreno gallo les renda est tout
heureux vous avez été dans cité dans
colisée ça doit être un petit peu
embêtant de voir son nom propre et comme
ça dans une enquête sur la mafia
c'est quand même pas banal d'être
associés aux gens de la mafia mais le
mot soucier c'est un gréement cas
on parle en disant que c'était la mafia
associés c'était notre site
c'est pas comme des amis comme ça que
c'est le premier café je suis pas soucié
avec la mafia littoraux dintrich a remis
deux mois moreno la même chose
le fils de mme renaud la même chose
sow je comprends pas que ça me demande
de me donner des problèmes moi mon nom y
est jamais sorti dans l'enquêté colisée
alors c'est sûr que c'est quand même un
peu bizarre que vous soyez un très bon
ami de vito rizutto de moreno gallo
quand même le top de la mafia à montréal
yachts et oui bien sûr par le passé mais
ce que c'est pas tout le monde sait pas
tout tous les individus de montréal qui
peuvent avoir accès facilement à vito
rizutto à moreno gallo
alors est ce que vous pensez qu'on
s'auto conclusion quand on vous associé
à la mafia parce que vous êtes proche de
ces gens là oui oui vraiment oui c'est
pas la vérité parce que c'est moi je
suis approché vitaux ou me raynaud je ne
fais pas partie de ces affaires ce que
je comprenais j'ai pas d'école de
commerce avec moreno roue de vito
rizzuto des amis personnels
c'est des amis personnels s'est pas
associé d'un se comprend moi j'ai moi
quand je parle avec des taux
c'est pas parce qu'elle lui était le nom
qui était le chef de la mafia pour moi
c'est vito bons amis ce que je comprends
la même chose avec moreno c'est moi je
l'échangé là je n'ai jamais à la maison
de
de veto mais il est venu chez moi moi
j'étais à la mesure de moreno on a vu
des amis mais ça finit là mais vous
aviez jamais pardonné d'être proche de
ses genres musicaux de croix ben c'est
pas un milieu particulièrement
sécuritaire c'est moi je fais bien de
même si je fais un lien
pourquoi non peut-être que vous vous
étiez possible mais vous avez vu comment
comment moreno gallo a fini ses jours
comme un vito rizutto bon évidemment il
est mort d'une maladie c'est autre chose
mais il ya quand même passé des années
en prison
oui est-ce que je repère dans ma vie
pourquoi parce que j'étais je parlais
avec des taux élevés n'est morte à
manger ensemble le café un bien non
c'était tout le temps